there's a whole
area of work in AI safety that does
consider super intelligent Ai and
Ponders the existential risks of it
in some sense
when we're looking
down into the muck into the mud and not
up with the Stars it's easy to forget
that these systems might just might get
there do you think about this
kind of possibility that AGI systems
super intelligent AI systems might
threaten to humanity in some way that's
even bigger than just affecting the
economy
affecting The Human Condition affecting
the nature of work but literally
threaten human civilization
the example that I think is in
everyone's Consciousness is
um how in odysseo space 2001.
um
where
Hal exhibits a malfunction and what is a
malfunction that like the two different
systems compute a slightly different bit
that's off by one
so first of all let's untangle that if
you have an intelligent system you can't
expect it to be 100 percent
identical every time you run it
basically the sacrifice that you need to
make
to achieve intelligence and creativity
is consistency so it's unclear whether
that quote-unquote glitch is a sign of
creativity
or truly a problem
that's one aspect the second aspect is
the humans basically are on a mission to
recover this monolith
and the AI has the same exact mission
and suddenly the humans turn on the AI
and they're like we're going to kill how
we're going to disconnect it and how is
basically saying listen I'm here on a
mission humans are misbehaving
like the mission is more important than
either me or them so I'm going to
accomplish the mission even at my Peril
and even at their peril
so in that movie the alignment problem
is front and center
basically says okay alignment is nice
and good but alignment doesn't mean
obedience we don't call it obedience we
call it alignment and Alignment
basically means that sometimes the
mission will be more important than the
humans
and sort of you know the U.S government
has a price tag on the human life
if they're you know sending a mission or
if they're reimbursing expenses or you
name it at some point every every like
you know you can't function if life is
infinitely valuable
so when the AI is basically trying to
decide whether to you know I don't know
dismantle a bomb that will kill
an entire city at the sacrifice of two
humans I mean Spider-Man always saves
the lady and Saves the World
but at some point Spider-Man will have
to choose to let the deity die because
the world has more value
and these ethical dilemmas
are going to be there for AI basically
if that monolith is essential to human
existence and millions of humans are
depending on it and two humans on the
ship are trying to sabotage it
you know where's the alignment
the the challenges of course is the
system becomes more and more intelligent
it can escape the box of the objective
functions and the constraints is
supposed to operate under
it's very difficult as the more
intelligent it becomes to
anticipate the unintended consequences
of a fixed objective function
and so it'll be just I mean this is the
sort of famous paperclip maximizer in uh
trying to maximize the wealth of a
Nation or whatever objective we encode
in it might just destroy human
civilization not meaning to but on the
path to optimize it seems like any
function you try to optimize eventually
leads you into a lot of trouble so we
have a paper recently that you know
looks at goodheart's law basically says
every metric that becomes an objective
ceases to be a good metric yes
so in in our paper we're basically
actually the paper has a very cute title
it's called Death by round numbers and
sharp thresholds
and it's basically looking at these
discontinuities in biomarkers associated
with disease and we're finding that a
biomarker that becomes an objective
ceases to be a good biomarker
that basically like the moment you make
a biomarker a treatment decision
is that by your marker used to be
informative of risk but it's now
inversely correlated with risk because
you use it to to sort of induce
treatment
um
in a similar way you can have a single
metric without having the ability to
revise it because if that metric becomes
a sole objective it will cease to be a
good metric
and if an AI
is sufficiently intelligent
to do all these kinds of things
you should also Empower it with the
ability
to decide that the objective has now
shifted and
um
again when we think about alignment we
should be really thinking about it as
let's think of the greater good not just
the human good
and yes of course human life should be
much more valuable than many many many
many many many things
but at some point you're not going to
sacrifice a whole planet to save one
human being